[موسيقى]
يفتي كثير من المفتين وعلماء الدين بوجوب
مقاطعه البضائع والسلع التي يمكن
الاستغناء عنها والتي تدعم شركاتها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بطريقه مباشره او حتى
بالموا ربه تنشر الفتاوى فياتي من يقول
قاطعوا اذا طائراتهم ولا تسافر على متنها
وتخلوا عن ادويتهم فيرد عليه مبدا
المقاطعه يقوم على الاستغناء عن كل سلعه
يمكن التخلي عنها كما افتوا دون الاضرار
بمعيشة حظرا اقتصاديا على السودان استثنت
منه الصمغ العربي الذي تنتجه السودان فلم
تقاطعه لانه يلزمها في صناعه مشروبات
غازيه تدعم الغزات وانت لم تبادر بعد الى
مقاطعتها
يقولون الى
العناوين عميد تونسي نخبه كتائب القسام لم
تدخل المعركه بعد وتحضر
لمفاجئة
يقتادون سفينه يملكها اسرائيلي وحزب الله
يدمر ثكنه للاحتلال
هرتس تفجر المفاجاه مروحيه اسرائيليه هي
التي قصفت حفله غلاف
غزه شيخ يدعو المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى ترك
الجهاد والاشتغال
بالسنن وزير الصحه المصري قرار ادخال جرحى
زه الى
مستشفياتنا ليس
[موسيقى]
بيدنا مرحبا هل ان غزه وحدها مسرح حروب
اسرائيل الحاضره والمستقبليه على العرب
ايمان حكومه تل ابيب الذي اكده نتنياهو
قبل ايام بما يصفونه بنبوه اشعياء يكرس
حدود اسرائيل من الفرات الى النيل
يطرح هذا السؤال مع مواصله الاحتلال
انتصاراته على نساء غزه واطفالها
ومستشفياتها ومدارسها وجامعاتها ومعاهدها
ومساجدها وكنائسها وافران خبزها وسبل
مائها وعلى كل شيء ينبض فيها بالحياه في
مسرح عمليات اسمه قطاع غزه لم يشح عالم
الحروب الهمجيه وجهه عنه بل فتح عيونه
يكحلها بدماء ستثق مستقبلا لا شك انه ات
يجري نهر الدم الفلسطيني بخشوع من القتله
الذين يؤدون طقوسهم الدينيه على انقاض
بيوت سكنيه دمروها على رؤوس اهلها قبل ان
يقيموا صلاه شكر ميدانيه على تمكنهم من
سفك دماء الاطفال والنساء الابرياء قبل
اعلان هدنه الايام الاربعه بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل بوسطه قطريه ومصريه
قال المحلل العسكري التونسي العميد
المتقاعد توفيق ديدي انه مع التفاوت
الكبير في ميزان القوى كان يفترض ان ينهي
جيش الاحتلال حربه العدوانيه خلال ثلاثه
ايام فقط لكن المقاومه تفوقت على جيش
احتلال بشريا بما يفتقده مقابل مقاومه
عندها اسلحه فرديه المفروض ثلاث ايام و
فات حرب وفات الحرب لكن الفرق ماما قلت هو
كلمتين الواعز الفرق هو القلب انا مقاتل
مدرب عندي في نفس الوقت رجوليه والتدريب
هذو ناس مدربين را باش يجي مقاتل يمشي يحط
متفجر فوق دبابه وهو مترجل را بالله فكر
لحظ شنو ه المقاتله ش عنده في قلبه
يفكروني في المقاتلين الفيتنام را يقتلوا
100 يخرجهم 1000 يقتلوا 1000 يخرجهم 10000
وهكذا دول العميد ديدي يقول ان نخبه
القسام لم تدخل المعركه بعد وستصنع
المفاجات في الميدان اليوم المفاجاه
الكبرى مش هذك را راهم 100 الا منو من ال
نخبه وتحبوا الجيش الاسرائيلي يسمعها هذ
نحبوا يسبحها ال 10 الا من قوه النخبه
اتاع حماس لم تقح في المركه لحد الان اللي
دخل المعركه وقلت عليه عده مرات را زمر
صغيره قعده
يعني تناوش في العدو في نوع حرب استنزاف
ضرب العدو ثم تخفي القتال مع ك اشباح نضرب
العدو نضمر ثم بعد ثواني
نختفي قوات النخبه علاش قادره نجم تعمل
هذك تكون
مفاجاه عزيز الرويبضه اذا كنت ما بتعرف
طعم تمك ما تنتقد اكل امك بعض المطبعين
الصغار يستعجلون نهايه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه فيما الاسرائيليون انفسهم لا
يرون هذا الهدف قريب
المنال اي ماذا تبقى لاسرائيل من اهداف
هذا التدمير الرهيب مع ما يحمله استهداف
المشافي من رمزيه لاعدام الحياه هل فعلا
كان نتنياهو يريد ان يضحي باسرا في غزه من
اجل انقاذ نفسه كما يتهمه دان حالوتس الذي
قال ان اسرائيل مخطوفه معهم الان في غزه
الامين العام للاتحاد العالمي لعلماء
المسلمين الشيخ علي القرداغي سال بفيديو
تعبيري كيف س يخرج جيش الاحتلال من
غزه حتى لو قطعوا الشجره لا شيء يضمن
سلامه راس الثور من النزيف شيء اخر نزف
وشبع موتا هو مصداقيه اسرائيل امام
الاعلام الغربي الذي تورط بعضه بتبني
روايه المعتدي ويحاول الان لملمه مهنيته
تقرير نشرته شبكه ان بي سي نيوز الامريكيه
سلط الضوء على الاخطاء في المعلومات التي
كانت تعلن عنها اسرائيل خصوصا في ملفي
مستشفى الرنتيسي والشفاء ما جعلها موضع
سخريه عبر الانترنت ومواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بي بي سي تحاول ايضا استعاده
توازن معلوماتها حول غزه فتقدم شهاده
جديده عن مستشفى الشفاء تنسف مزاعم
الاحتلال رغم محاولته التلاعب بمسرح
الجريمه describes theif hospital as the
main headquarters for hamas terrorist
activity this idf animation posted in
late october claims to represent a hamas
tunnel system underneath the hospital
but having been inside alifa since early
wednesday israel yet to produce evidence
of the tunnels it has allowed the bbc
and fox news to film at the hospital
though only locations of israel's choice
they israel also
own
افا اسم الدلع الفلسطيني لافي خي ادرعي
اعتقل في محبس سرديه عسكره المشافي لا سما
الشفاء شفاه
الله الو
المستشفى السلام عليكم حبيت اسالك عندكم
بالمستشفى بجوار جهاز الام ار اي عندكم
بنادق شنوف بونسوار افا بينتنا فيه في
رزنامه على الحيط لا مش انت الحيط
الرزنامه على الحيط اذا بيهمك والله في
مستشفى شفا في غزه عندهم كثير كوف من ورا
جهاز الام ار اي الله يغضب عليهم الله
يغضب عليهم هيدي مش لك يا تقبرني هيدي معك
فيها شهاده حصريه لا تناقص بهيز بيحكي انا
متاكد انه عندكم نفق عسكري عمليات كبير
بجوار المبنى داخل المجمع التبي اليس كذلك
لما في في مستشفى الشفاء عندهم نفق ك بير
لحماس وارهاب وفي مستشفى الغلت عندهم نفق
استراتيجي كبير جدا للقتال وفي اسلحه في
جوره مصعد اسانسور انتبه ما تفك رقبتك
فيها زميلك الفتح وقع ولهلا ما طلع منا
حبيت اسالك عند في المستشفى في طابق
السفلي عندكم انتم تحتجز رهائن يعني
مختطفين
واسلحه يعني ما فيش اي مختطفين ما فيش اي
رين يعني تعرف انه في مستشفى القدس
ومستشفى الرنتيسي عندهم يعني في مستشفى
الرنتيسي في غزه كانوا يحتجزون رين افا
انت بالطبيعي منك راكب على بعضك شو بدك
بالتمثيل طلب وحيد من بهيج انك تيل المصحف
من قدامك لانه مصحف شريف وانت بتقتلو
الصغار مثلكم مثل السرطان لكن السرطان لا
ينكر ذلك كما
تنكرون لشيخ الكذابين وهو يحتضر بين
المنافقين اوصنا يا كبيرنا وصيه الاباء
للبنين قال ان فعلتم لا تستحوا اكذبوا ما
شئتم على العالمين نفاق وخجل لا يجتمعان
تظاهروا بانكم على يقين وان غبت عنكم فبعد
مماتي لا تذهبوا شمالا ولا يمين خليفه في
الافك من بعد تجربه ذلك المكنى بابني
كوهين لانه الان في ترند على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي تحت عنوان الخبر اليقين
عند كوهين هذا على ضوء شو دكتور ايدي
الفيديو اللي نشرته حضرتك للانفاق في
السويد والتي قلت انها في غزه وينكن يا ما
بعرف مين لحتى هذا الفيديو عندي هون على
التليفون تعالوا شوفوا نحن شو عم نعمل
بحماس شوي بيطلع انه النفق بالسويد طيب ان
كنتم تنتصرون في غزه ما الداعي الى اخبار
باقل تعبير مفبركه هذا الفيديو انا انشر
ماذا اريد انا بنشره ولا احقق ولا احقق
اذا اذا كان هذا ما عندي
الاساليب اذا طلع مفرك طلع مفبرك يعني
بتعرف شو طلع هلا طلع انه الخبر اليقين مش
عند كوهين عندما تكون عصابات المافيا
مدعومه من السلطه فانها لن تهتم بسمعتها
العصيه اصلا على الغسل
والتنظيف عسكر الاحتلال التق ط صوره مع
مسن فلسطيني مريض ثم اعدموه رميا بالرصاص
لتعثر عائلته على جثته مرميه على الطريق
التي زعمت اسرائيل انه امن لعبور المدنيين
الى جنوب القطاع احد جنود الاحتلال المح
الى دور لهم في منع عبور
الرجال
وقد استشهد ثلاثه صحفيين في قصف اسرائيلي
استهدفهم قرب بلده طير حرفا جنوبي لبنان
ونعت قناه الميادين في بيروت مراسلتها في
جنوب لبنان فرح عمر والمصور ربيع معماري
كما استشهد في القصف حسين عقيل الذي يعمل
كصحفي متعاونا معهما ما تزال قوافل
الشهداء في لبنان وفلسطين تحمل المزيد من
الصحفيين
وعائلاتهم الصحفي مصطفى الصواف استشهد
ايضا مع زوجته وابنه المصور الصحفي بقصف
اسرائيلي استهدف منزلهم في غزه كما استشهد
الصحفيان ساري منصور وحسونه سليم الذي وجه
نداء استغاثه قبيل استشهاده انا طالح هذا
الفيديو ومش عارف اذا ممكن اطلع بكمان
فيديو احنا كصحفي في غزه معرضين في اي وقت
للاستهداف الا الله السيد حبيب الله لا
اله الا الله والسيد حبيب الله لا اله الا
الله وحسنا حبيب الله حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل زميلنا الصحفي ساري جمال منصور
الذي تم استهداف منزله دون سابق انزار
ورسالتنا للام العربيه والاسلاميه اللي
بتسمعنا انقذوا غزه غزه تتعرض لاباده
جماعيه قالت جماعه الحوثي ان السفينه التي
اقتادت يوم الاحد الى شواطئ اليمن هي
اسرائيليه واعتبر جيش الاحتلال الحادثه
بانه خطير للغايه عالميا في حين وصفته
رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه بالعمل
الارهابي الايراني ايران نفت صلتها بالمو
فيما قالت طوكيو ان السفينه تدار من قبل
شركه يابانيه وطالبت
باطلاقها حزب الله يدمر ثكنه تابعه لجيش
الاحتلال والاتي اكبر اذا توسعت الحرب
يقول الامين العام لحزب الله كشف حزب الله
عن اسلحه وتكتيكات جديده بدا يستخدمها في
عمليات الحربيه خصوصا بعدما اعلن عن
استهداف مركز قياده الفرقه 91 للجيش
الاسرائيلي في ثكنه برانيت الاسرائيليه
باربعه صواريخ بركان من العيار الثقيل
وبحسب نصر الله ان هذه الصواريخ لا تشكل
الا جزءا صغيرا من اسلحه الحزب ومن
المتوقع اللجوء الى استراتيجيات اكبر اذا
توسعت رقعه الحرب وهو ما يتركه في خانه
[موسيقى]
المفاجات في هذا الظرف العصيب هل تكفي
الاموال التي تقدمها دوله قطر لدعم 100 ال
اسره فقيره جدا في قطاع غزه المحاصر ام
يجب رفع مستوى الدعم القطري والاسلامي
عموما ليشمل كل اهل غزه فعندما يتحول
الامير تميم الى سوبر هيرو بالنسبه لاطفال
غزه هذا يعني انه يقوم بعمل اكثر من مهم
واكثر من رائع تخيلي انه بناء لاتفاق
استخباراتي قطري مصري اسرائيلي بالاضافه
الى حماس ستضخ قطر 30 مليون دولار شهريا
مع نهايه هذا العام لقطاع غزه من طرف
الجبه تماما قالت صحيفه معارف الصهيونيه
ذلك لكنه يعتبر حياه بكاملها بالنسبه
لسكان قطاع غزه اهل غزه ارادوا رفع الحصار
الجائر عنهم وبعد ذلك هم كفيلون
بقطاع مشكله اسرائيل معهم يقول شيخ ازهري
ان الغزيين احبوا الحريه واحترموا الشهاده
اكثر من حبهم لكره القدم ومن اقساط البنوك
حاربونا خذوا اولادنا اموالنا كلها في
سبيل الله كل في سبيل الله لا نخاف ولا
نهاب
الحمدلله
صمت لو
تكلم الناس قا قوتنا وبس واللي عملناه
احنا فيش دول اللي عملته ولا بيقدروا
يعملوه من
الاخر ان شاء الله على التحرير باذن الله
خلص اسرا عروسهم راح مننا اربع خمس شهداء
فداك يا
فلسطين فلسطين الامير تركي الفيصل في
منتدى حوار المنامه يحمل اسرائيل مسؤوليه
ما وصفه بوصول الاموال لحركه حماس في غزه
من قبل دوله
[موسيقى]
قطر ولي عهد البحرين الامير سلمان بن حمد
ال خليفه دان قتل المدنيين في غزه كما
عمليه طوفان الاقصى انطلاقا مما وصفه
بايمانه الابراهيمي واتهم كتائب القسام
بقتل الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ
الاسرائيليين بالايمان الابراهيمي اذا
الامر سيان ان انقاذ الارواح هو اشبه
بانقاذ كل البشريه انا ادين حماس بدون اي
شك اقف الى جانب الابرياء
والمدنيين وليس الى بموقف سياسي ان
الهجمات التي حصلت في السابع من تشرين
الاول هي كانت بربريه لم تميز بين الناس
قتل الاطفال والنساء والعجزه في موضوع
اسرائيل انا ادين وبلا اي وبكل وضوح عفوا
الهجمات الجويه التي ادت الى مقتل اكثر من
11000 نسمه في غزه 4000 ونيف هم من اطفال
صحيفه هارت العبريه تفجر مفاجاه مروحيه
عسكريه اسرائيليه هي التي قتلت محتفلين
اسرائيليين في حفله غلاف غزه الموسيقيه
الشهيره يوم طوفان الاقصى تزيح صحيفه
هارتس الستاره عن مفاجاه مدويه حيث نشرت
تقريرا افاد بان مروحيه تابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي وصلت لمكان الحفل المقام في
احدى مستوطنات غلاف غزه واطلقت النار على
مقاتلي حماس وجمهور من المشاركين في الحفل
بحسب مصدر للشرطه كما يرى مسؤولون في
الجيش الاسرائيلي وفق الصحيفه لان حركه
حماس لم تكن على علم مسبق بتوقيت المهرجان
معلومات نقلتها الصحيفه عن مسؤولين امنيين
تحقيقات اوليه تؤكد شكوك بعض المراقبين
وتمنحهم تفسيرا لاحتراق السيارات حينها
وتفحم الجثث لانه ايضا كان هناك جثث متفح
لمقاتلين من كتائب القسام بمعنى جثث
محترقه من من كان يتواجد من الاجانب في
هذا الاحتفال وايضا من كتائب القسام اذا
من الجهتين كيف حرقت هذه الجثث هذا هو
السؤال الذي بقي مطروحا شيخ يدعى هشام
البيلي يدعو حركه حماس الى ترك المقاومه
والاستعاده عنها
بالسنن والله يا شيخ اذا كنت بحاجه لعمليه
قلب مفتوح فلن تفضل تقويم
اسنانك ولا حتى تقويم لسانك بدلا عن قلبك
المفتوح يا ابا عبيده جاهد بالسنن ان كنت
صادقا اعظم من الجهاد بالسيوف يا ابا
عبيده ان كنت جاهلا فتعلم رساله لك جاهد
بالسنن جاهد بالسنن جاهد
بالسكوت جاهد بالسكوت يا لكع ابن لكع جاهد
بالصمت جاهد بالصمت رحم الله امرا تكلم
فغنم او سكت
فسلم فجاهد بالسكوت جاهد بالسكوت ولولا
رتقه لا تجوز ما رد الحسين على الاراجوز
بخلاف الشيخ هشام بيلي وقفت الراقصه في في
عبده وقفه عز مع غزه قلبي كله مع غزه حرام
عليهم اللي هم عاملينه واحنا بنبكي دم في
البيوت ليه ليه كده ليه كده تده طار بي
خصوه مثلا ولا ايه الفلسطينيين دول دول مش
اهلينا برض ليه كده بنشوف اللي مش ممكن
نشوفه ب وصلت ان الكلاب تاكل جثثنا ليه يا
ناس حرام عليكم والله خبر مزعج للمطبعين
الرافضين لدعوات المقاطعه عبر تويتر
ويقولون قاطعوا منصه اكس تويتر الامريكيه
اذا اذا اردتم ان تقاطعوا اما الخبر فهو
ان المنصه ايلون ماسك متهم بالترويج
لمعدات الساميه وفي البيت الابيض ايلون
ماسك في مرمى نيران البيت الابيض الذي دان
ما ورد منذ ايام في منشور على منصه اكس
تبنى فيه ماسك نظريه مؤامره معاديه
للساميه المنشور قيد الجدل جاء فيه ان
المجتمعات اليهوديه تدفع بالكراهيه
العنصريه ضد البيض ثم تزعم انها تريد من
الناس التوقف عن استخدام مثل هذه الكرا هي
ضدها منشور قام ماسك بمشاركته معقبا عليه
بالقول ان هذه هي الحقيقه الفعليه استطاع
يساريون اسرائيليون ان يتظاهروا في تل
ابيب ضد عدوان جيشهم على غزه لكن
فلسطينيين لم يتمكنوا من التظاهر في رام
الله يا اب
عبيش رام الله الم بشكل عفوي وفي مشهد غير
مالوف استطاع محمود وغيره التجمهر في
مدينه رام الله معقل السلطه الفلسطينيه
واجهزتها الامنيه قبل ان تق مععهم اجهزه
الامن الفلسطينيه عواصم العالم من نيويورك
الى كوالالمبور مرورا بلندن واسطنبول
وعمان نظمت تظاهرات داعمه ومتضامن مع غزه
فكيف تقمع تظاهره في رام الله شقيقه غزه
وزير الصحه المصري الصادق يعترف بان قرار
نقل الجرحى من غزه الى المستشفيات المصريه
ليسي
القاهره
egy don't but certainly there is someone
that has to check and has to clear out
and give the clear for those patients to
come out from territories the egyptian
side but i told you my team and my staff
are staying day and night waiting for
every single case to get in to start
dealing think
isal out have to
نائب مصري يحمل مسؤوليه ما يجري في غزه
الى عدم وجود رئيس استثنائي فيها الخير
اللي بلدنا فيه من ايه من ربنا اولا ومن
سياده الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي وقفتنا في
سطحنا وفي بلكونتنا وبنشي وعزمي ناس
وقاعدين بنعمل اكل وفرحانين ومبسوطين
الامن والامان اللي الدنيا كلها محرومه
منه
وفلسطين اللي الناس بتتدبح فيها وبلاد
تانيه كتير الناس اللي بتقول مش عارفين
ناكل لا ده انتوا عايشين مرتاحين ومبسوطين
وبتاكل احلى اكل واحلى شرب في ناس دلوقتي
مش لاقيه شويه كهربا عشان ترضع بنتها ولا
شويه ميه عشان تاكل ابنها ولا مستشفى تدخل
فيها عيلها ولا اي حاجه من الحاجات الخير
الكبير اللي احنا عايشين فيه والامن اللي
احنا راضيين بيه يقال ان جيلا مسلما
وعربيا من الاطفال يكبرون الان على ذاكره
طوفان الاقصى وقد اصبح ابو عبيده نجمهم
المفضل يتابعون اطلالاته الاعلاميه قبل
الكبار طفله عربيه لا تحسن النطق بعد
شاهدت عامل بناء من الشرفه يعتمر كوفيه
حمراء فظنت انه ابو عبيده
عبيده في محافظه اب باليمن خطاب الخريجين
الجامعيين القاه طالب ظهر بهيئه ابو عبيده
هذه الحله الاستثنائيه لمن يتحلق الملايين
حول الشاشات بانتظار بيانه وحركه من بنانه
فارس بلا ملامح لكنه يضج هيبه ورهبه قائد
الحرب الاعلاميه والنفسيه ضد الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وضابط ايقاعها الملثم
ابو عبيده في السابع من اكتوبر التاريخ
الذي سيتحدث عنه الاجيال ستروى قصصه في
حكايات وحتو تات الصغار والكبار السابع من
اكتوبر طوفان
الاقصى اخيرا النجم الكروي المغربي
والعالمي ياسين بونو يكسر حصار غزه صوتا
وصوره متواصلا مع طفل بترت قدمه وكان حلمه
ان يصبح مثل بونو وان يلتقي به طفل عاصف
كان حلمه انه يجري مكالمه مع لاعب كره
القدم او والحارس ياسين بونو اليوم راح
يتحقق حلم عاصف كيف حالك
ياسين كيف حالك كيف
حالك
بخير احسن والله يا سين والله انا بحبك
ياسين بحبك والله انت قدلي بالنسبه انا ان
شاء الله موعدك روح شوفك ان شاء الله ليش
بتعيط
[موسيقى]
خليه ختاما ما يوصف
بنبوءة الى حكوماتها لاتخاذ الموقف
والاستعداد ام ان المخابرات منشغله بتسجيل
خطب الجمعه والحوارات
التلفزيونيه الى اللقاء حكامنا انتم
مصيبتنا انتم اساس بلائنا
ونكبت اهتزت كل الدنيا لمصاب غزه لرجالها
لنسائها لشيوخ لاطفالها التي في كل يوم
تذوي وتذوب وانتم كالاصنام ولك العربي في
الجاهليه حتى قبل الاسلام كان عنده دم
عنده شرف عنده نخوه عنده مروءه يجير من
استجار انتم ماذا بربكم اما حركتكم هذه
المشاهد
والصور الم تحرك شيء فيكم انتم حكام لا
والله
محكومين
[موسيقى]
ان